now what i went through in jacksonville
i was defending myself you know
you know what i'm saying at the end of
the day we got to protect our brains so
you can't just
certain people ain't going out the same
way like you can't just walk up on
certain artists because certain artists
really come from the streets and you
know i'm saying they got a lot of [ __ ]
at home they got to make it back to kids
family mom dad
yeah so yeah that so some something
similar that happened to the baby
happened to you
yeah but
what was the circumstance i was um
finishing my last mistake love me like
i'm dead last call i was at a like a
public studio in jacksonville and as i
was walking out of studio
my car i got shot at along my car like
getting this out of my car and i shot
back and sell the fence like you know
i'm saying that [ __ ] was just another
wild ass situation that she was all over
the noodles everywhere did uh anything
did you end up hitting anybody um
i made them drop they clipped though and
i got grazed to like that ankle though
some [ __ ] i did see you got shot or
grazed i guess that's right great
shot yeah um
it's that's that's that's kind of
in your hometown yeah obviously
jacksonville probably for use hotter
than any other city
in terms of just people not wanting to
see you you know
do your thing um
did you come out of that situation like
what because when you're that close to
you know that bullets a foot up a foot
to the right or you know
that dudes aims a little bit better
yeah it could be all bad for you did
that [ __ ] like um
kind of like
do anything to you as far as just
changing your mentality or or changing
the way you think the way you move
really i wasn't even supposed to be at
that studio i got too comfortable and i
knew in my head i went for it to be at
that studio just recording but i was
just
trying to finish my mistake for my fans
and get it turned in and get a little um
just to let them hear what i'm like my
new sound you know what i'm saying but i
wasn't supposed to be at that studio in
jasmine that was really all on me
like you kind of knew you weren't
supposed to be there yeah you're like
you know what i left myself i was i was
i was sitting here and yeah
100
yeah i i do see that happening a lot
like you know i think sometimes
when you're from a certain area you you
that's where you're going to let your
guard down most of the time and that's
probably where you shouldn't you know
that's what happened obviously dolph was
at home in memphis when he when he got
when he got got and uh
that's crazy man damn
so um
you
the cops come
question you thank god it happened in
florida because
most states
you return fire
if you're in california and you fight
and you return fire it's all bad they
don't give a [ __ ] out here you go to
jail
if you if the gun's not registered if
the california's just a weird state like
as far as defending yourself yeah yeah
so at least in florida there's like the
standard ground law and you know you
could be like yeah i was defending
myself so
yeah so that was the end of that
yep i had um
after that situation they had took my
gun i'm gonna get my guns back though
but they had took my guns ramblishes and
[ __ ] to make sure i would tell them the
truth
yeah man we're good for you bro mm-hmm
did you have any idea who did it
obviously don't tell us but did you have
any any idea i was at a public studio so
immediately anyway yeah i'm saying a
million people come to the studio in a
session before me session after me so
someone hop on the phone yo who else in
the studio get what i'm saying
or anybody so i was just like in the
midst of some [ __ ] i went for to be